so Greta tell us about your writing
process for this movie well it took me
it took me a very long time to write it
I tend to take a long time to write
because I wish I didn't but that's just
kind of how it goes I I started with
wanting to make something about home and
how home is something you only can
really understand as you're leaving and
I knew I wanted the core of it to be a
love story between a mother and a
daughter and I don't I start with a
hunch and a kind of general sense of it
but I don't I don't know what its gonna
be until I start making it and and I
think I spent a lot of time letting the
characters talk to me and tell me who
they are and then I I wind up with a
very long draft which I then have to cut
down and that's what I did on this one
and then I you know I I don't write with
actors in mind but if I had I I would
there's no better actors I could have
possibly thought of to to have to work
with so Saoirse and Greta sort of
connected at the Toronto Film Festival
in 2015 you both happen to be there and
you had to kind of read through I guess
and and can you talk a little bit about
what happened and why you became
involved in the film yeah and I mean I
became involved or wanted to be involved
instantly as soon as I knew it was Greta
script and she's someone who I've always
admired and always been a very big fan
of and she knows that um and we we I
read it and of course I loved it because
look at how great it was and AM and we
did a Skype meeting which was the giddy
escape meeting I've ever had was not
professional at all it was like two best
friends that hadn't seen each other all
summer and had finally come back
together and and then we met in Toronto
and I remember I had just flown in to do
press for Brooklyn and Greta had flown
in from it
that she had been shooting on and we
went through the whole script and it
just felt like you had kind of met your
person a little bit felt like you met
the person that you just want to make
everything with you know and which means
you have to put me in every single one
of your films now with her but but yeah
and that and that was it really we
clicked and then a year later we we got
to make it but it was lovely also after
Greta allowed me to come on board that
we had the year to sort of stay in touch
and talk about things and meet up in New
York and it was good to have that time
to let it breathe a little bit you know
Laurie you and Tracy had sort of
travelled in the same circles in theatre
but you had never worked together before
is that right yeah that's right and so
what was it like kind of creating a
family on set did you guys do some
rehearsals or how did you sort of find
that Saoirse and I got to rehearse and I
hear that euro said oh you'd never got
the rear I didn't get any damn role but
I knew that Tracy and I would be on the
same page right away we just share the
same
I don't know work style I guess and
sense of humor and and everything was on
the page everything was scripted by
Greta so it was really easy to click
into the this this family dynamic Tracy
as a writer yourself what was your
experience reading the script what did
you make of it it was it's what you see
up there the the movie in my mind when I
read it is the movie that Greta made
that's not always the case the script
was very tight I don't remember it going
through a lot of changes between the
time I read it at the time we shot it I
don't recall it going through a lot of
changes on the set I mean she was open
to change stuff if we needed to but for
the most part it was all there's
everything you need to play the role
which makes our job just that much
easier John the music evokes a very
specific moment in time can you tell us
what your conversations were with Greta
about the music for this film well it's
supposed to be just that
that moment and somebody's life you know
you sense they're supposed to be more
but you can't articulate it yet and you
know we all understand that one in fact
it's a point you can find yourself and
multiple times in your life so there's a
certain sort of bittersweet thing to
that yearning but it's nonspecific so it
was more about chasing something that
echoed that feeling and usually for us
and we were sitting around working when
it was right we knew it and we both sort
of point at the same time and then it
was done
Saoirse is there a difference when
you're acting for someone who's also an
actor I think there can be yeah I mean
in this case there definitely was
because well yeah actually any time I
worked was a director who's also an
actor there's a sensitivity there and an
understanding for what we do and
regardless of how an actor works the
sort of process I suppose an actor's
mind goes through when they're creating
a role and all that and you know even if
you're kind of you know you have a thick
enough skin I think it's still it's a
vulnerable thing to do and so to have
someone who was so sensitive to that
really helped because Greta could be
strong for us when we needed someone to
be strong and she could allow us to take
the lead when we felt we could do it on
her own I mean it honestly felt like she
was our mother for the whole thing it
did and I think that's what a great
director does it's like the equivalent
to a great parent somebody who like you
know gives you that discipline and that
structure but also gives you like the
love and the freedom to feel like you
can do anything Greta you had done a lot
of different jobs on on films you you've
written you've co-directed you've acted
and you've been in many independent
films where you have to sort of help out
with all the gigs on on a set how did
you decide that this was the movie where
you were going to take on directing solo
well I thought I've always wanted to be
a director I've always specifically
be a writer-director as something that I
wrote and and like you were saying at
all these things I've done and I didn't
go to film school so so this is with all
this time that I've spent on sets doing
different jobs has been my film school
and it's an extraordinary way to learn
because I've been able to be around so
many great directors and
cinematographers and sound mixers and
production designers and costume
designers and I've gotten to see how
different people run things and and
figure it out and when I finished this
script I knew I knew that if I didn't do
it now I would not I would never do it
and there's always more to learn but I
think I'd reached the point where the
learning would happen by doing I wasn't
going to keep learning on the sidelines
anymore and and I just decided to go to
jump there are a lot of great
coming-of-age movies that capture a sort
of boy at the age that this movie
depicts not as many that capture a girl
at this age what was why was this
particular age of interest to you well
you know I think it's what John just
said so beautifully about the yearning
for something you don't quite know what
it is so there's that that is so vivid I
think particularly at 17 and for me I I
wanted to make a film where that the
primary question of this for this young
woman was was that of her coming into
her own person hood and what does that
mean to occupy that space and I think
often young female characters are given
validation through being chosen as a
romantic partner and she has her
romantic partners but I kind of wanted
to start from this premise of you know
what if there are two guys and they're
both wrong and the love stories with her
mother and that felt more true to life
to me and I felt like a way to
explore who's stepping into who she
already is in a way and and I that
that's the kind of story I'm interested
in thank you very much